where you go through to have your bags
x-rayed as An Almighty smash at the
front gate which is meters away from us
and immediately we saw police scramble
and armed officers responded gently
swiftly and shouted at the man to get
out of the car this was a silver Toyota
um
but I'd say 10 and officers pointing
rifles at the man
he was wrestled out of the car very
quickly and put down on the ground and
handcuffed and his pickle was insert we
were pushed through security as quickly
as possible and again brilliant response
from the police officers there they
formed the human shield to make sure
they were in the way at this stage we
have no idea what's happening uh it
could be a terrorist attack could be a
bomb attack could be an armed man and so
they they really put themselves between
us and the other people that were
delivering the petition we were
delivering a petition about the UK
welcoming Sudanese refugees in the same
way that we've offered wonderful
hospitality to ukrainians and we rushed
it to the back as far away from that
front gate as we could get uh push down
some stairs to build us in case anything
was to explode and then a few minutes
later I should out the back gate lots of
apologies that we couldn't deliver our
petition but they're putting everyone's
safety first we waited that gate and
pretty soon more police arrived some
people left Downing Street with a
recycle
um
compliment and then the whole place
became more and more shut down
yeah you say Chris you had a loud bang I
mean what was your initial thought
um it must have been pretty frightening
yeah
there were six of us there was
um
a lady from Ukraine a lady from Sudan
and some Sudanese gentlemen and you know
everyone was been responded incredibly
uh calmly and bravely but you know it
was a smash but I thought there'd been
an explosion I thought there might have
been a shots fired but you know that was
just the loud noise of the impact and
suddenly it's armed officers responding
very quickly very decisively shouting
clear instructions at the man about what
to do and he seems to be a middle-aged
man uh short stature and um you know he
he complied as as he was asked to
right but there's no indication of what
you know it was about whether as you say
there was a we've had a police officer
on say it could all be all sorts of
things from someone who simply had you
know driven very badly it could be a
mental health issue but the first
thought obviously as you mentioned there
is Terror but it clearly doesn't seem uh
that that is the case
yeah I I think the police used their
training to the utmost they needed to
reject a worst case scenario and respond
appropriately and they did and you know
we couldn't have been in better hands I
think they were definitely being better
safe than sorry you know it's very
difficult to round the front gate of
Downing Street it would be a pretty
bizarre uh maneuver to do that from the
rest of Whitehall so I think they made
the right choices under the
circumstances